We're going to use daily
returns as a basis for
the analysis in this lesson and we build
daily returns, like we've seen before,
by starting with a price time series.
And each point in this
daily return chart
is related to how much price has
changed on that corresponding day.
So, for instance,
this represents how much the price
changed from this day to that day,
about 1%.
And, of course, we have that for
each of the days in our history.
Now looking at this data, this daily
return data, it's not too revealing.
It's hard to draw any sorts of
interesting conclusions just by visually
looking at this data from day to day.
And so, there's a number of interesting
ways that we can look at that data, and
that's what this lesson is all about.
Those two ways are histograms and
scatter plots.
Let's start by taking
a look at histograms.
A histogram is a kind of bar chart
where we plot the number of occurrences
of each item versus the value.
So the way we accomplish that is,
we split up the range of data
into lots of little bins.
And we count up how many times the data
matches the range across that bin.
So, as an example, if you notice
here we've got several occurrences
of this value,
which is about the same, and
those three occurrences
are probably in say, this bin.
So when we go to plot
the histogram overall,
we would see a bar of
the appropriate height here
that represents how many times
the data matched that value.
And of course,
we have values in other bins, and so
the bars in those bins
would have various heights.
And as you gather that
data across all of time,
a shape emerges of this histogram, and
that provides a lot of information.
So let's consider what that
shape might look like.